for you uh speak to I guess your
mentality
um I feel like when you get incarcerated
it puts you through some some mental
anguish oh man
um how did you have to like how were you
able to still stay motivated and still
stay
I guess like saying going through that
because you you get locked up and kind
of like at the peak of your career at
the time
um how do you how do you get on get out
on the other side of that and and and
work and be bigger and better than ever
well because I know I have a long time
right was it a couple years like a year
years two years yeah so
in that two years I'm like [__] I'm
going here do what I need to do because
I know everything happened for a reason
you know what I'm saying even though I
went to jail for some serious [__] right
like I went to jail for what everybody
going to jail for now like the RICO like
I really went to jail for that you know
what I'm saying and I know I was in jail
for serious charges but it went for long
because I didn't have a criminal record
so right and that time I read books like
I never read you know what I'm saying
I left I dropped out of school in the
11th grade I didn't say I dropped out
like I dropped out of high school like I
dropped on 11th grade I went right
circumstances at home was kind of like
rough so I stopped going
but uh I went to school up until the
11th grade and uh what the [__] was I
saying uh you were talking about how you
just started to read you were reading in
jail I was reading
so I started by Reading Writing getting
my hand writing back because I sat in
the hole for three months so in that
time like I had to I couldn't do number
right 23 hours a day 24 hours a day in a
pandemic oh you know coming up really
facts and you gotta sell mate it's crazy
and you're just in there with a dude
that's in there non-stop nah stop and
and you know how they say ain't no two
days the same yeah every day the same
[__] man every day the same but what you
do get is is a piece of mind
you learn yourself
you sit back and it's quiet and you
figure out like what the [__] am I doing
back here
like what did I do like you know what
I'm saying and you thinking you figure
it out like I've never I cannot never
come back did you end up getting close
with this helmet
you want to know something funny
I don't know if you know uh I don't
really know if you remember like the guy
that went viral in the pandemic for like
making a jail video and [__] yeah he was
my cellmate in there oh really facts
that's crazy man when they put me in
there with him
I was like yo what the [__] they
Premiere with this guy for because I got
caught with a cell phone right
and it was weird as [__] I checked the
whole room for bugs and [__] I'm like
man this they put me here they trying to
trap me and [__] but you ended up being
cool as [__] hella intelligent like real
man got book stacked to the
yeah so you were able to uh you were
able to like kind of readjust some of
your you know like I mean you really
ain't got [__] else to do but read
and write read write writing a bunch of
raps
you know I I don't write so when I got
in there I'm like I gotta write some
music at least see on a normal basis you
you do punching in yeah so in jail you
got books of Rhymes now I wrote like 40
reps in there that's crazy yeah have you
that's 40 songs though you recorded them
I recorded Maybe
[Music]
when I came home I was making that [__]
go to beats like I just had so many of
them I'm like whatever go to would be
you know what I'm saying like like perk
10 I wrote that in jail I don't know if
you know that's it yeah I wrote that in
jail so that's a jail record
I wrote that in jail my last intro on a
free real album I wrote that in jail
uh
a couple more of them I wrote an arcade
thing off the head